Have you ever tried to make a song that
feels warm and alive like Joshua Sloan,
but it ends up feeling overproduced and
sterile. If you click this video
wondering who the hell Joshua Sloan even
is, he's like the biggest country and
folk artist out right now with his debut
album being at number two on the country
alternative charts. His album is full
with just lively, warm, and very human
sounding music. So, in this video, I'm
going to show you how to make a song
like that with a live off the- floor
kind of band in a room feeling. And
it'll be with tools you probably already
have in your bedroom studio. Step one,
acoustic guitar. For a recording like
this, we want more personality than
perfection. And we don't need any fancy
stereo mic setups. I just put one
microphone pointed around the 12th fret
on my acoustic guitar. I want it to feel
like there's just a player in a room.
All right, I'm going to set the tempo to
120. Feels pretty natural. I'm literally
just going to kind of come up with it as
I go. It's going to be a walk down.
Something to keep in mind. Um, that's a
chord that I don't even know if Josh
Sloan plays, but it feels like uh it
might be what he plays. So, this is like
how you play a regular F chord. [music]
you know, the bar chord. Um, but I
actually play it with this with my thumb
and I take my middle finger off.
So, you can do that or you can play like
a C-shape with an F in the bass.
Both have some different like colors to
it.
[music]
Now we've got a good start to the song,
but we want another instrument to play
dynamically with the acoustic guitar.
Which brings us to step two, electric
guitar. For this, we're going to pretty
much do the same thing, just use one
electric guitar track. I plugged my
Fender Stratacaster directly into my
interface, went into an amp sim, and I
panned it slightly off center, not hard
left or not hard right, just to make it
sound like there's someone kind of
standing off to the side in the room. So
now for the electric guitar, you're
going to play it sort of in the same
way. You're not going to use it for like
layers or loops or anything. You're
going to play it kind of throughout the
song dynamically very live. I'm going to
go in probably on the pre chorus. I
wanted to start with the acoustic
guitar.
[music]
Okay, cool. We've got some instruments
interacting with each other. Uh, but how
do we make the production sound bigger?
Well, for that, let's move on to step
three, which is piano. For this, I chose
an upright. I could have gone with a
grand, but I wanted to think about the
room that all these players are playing
in. Odds are it's not going to be a big
enough room for all these instruments
plus a big grand piano. And on top of
that, I think the upright piano has a
nice vintagey texture to it.
[music] Feels, you know, slightly dusty,
slightly more color. I think it fits the
vibe perfectly. And by the way, I'm
playing this piano on a MIDI keyboard,
specifically the Keystation 61. I
heavily recommend playing the piano on a
MIDI controller uh instead of clicking
in the notes. feels much more authentic,
much more natural, and you can react a
lot more than you can just clicking in
MIDI notes. Now, I've got the scale
thing on in Ableton. You can, I'm sure,
do this in other DAWs. Basically, it's
just transposing my MIDI up so that I
can play in the key of C. Well, I can
play the C notes,
but if I took off the scale, it would
actually be playing a different key.
So, just because I don't want to play in
the key of D#, I don't even know how to
play in the key of D# on piano. Um, I'm
just I just transposed it so I can play
all the notes
in the key of C. Now, I'm going to wait
until after the first chorus to bring
the piano in. I want it to be dynamic. I
want it to be exciting. I want to
introduce new things. And so, if I have
the piano throughout the entire song,
piano gets boring. So, let's just bring
the piano in after the first chorus. Um,
it'll also give a little bit of life to
the second verse.
Perfect. Now we've got a little live
band going on. But for this song
specifically, I want a heartbeat. So
next up is step four, drums. We don't
want the drums to sound huge or
overcompressed. This isn't a pop song or
a metal song. It's got to be pretty
folky, which would mean tight, a little
roomy, and playing pretty lightly. Now,
I swear by this library. It's a superior
drummer library. It's called the Singer
Songwriter EasyX, and it sounds super,
super good. It sounds like this.
Again, it's much better to use a MIDI
controller. You can react better. Plus,
up until this point, you've been pretty
lively with your performances. So,
clicking in drums is kind of going to
reverse all of that. As for the actual
drum part, I'm just keeping it very,
very simple. It's going to be something
like this.
>> [music]
>> and just variations of that. Some might
just have the side stick.
I'll probably use that for like some
verses. Um, and then the courses are
probably going to have a ride
with a crash in it. It's not going to be
that crazy. Um, I think maybe in the
precourse we'll bring it in. Um, I'm not
entirely sure yet. We can always move
it.
[music]
Now, you'll notice this ambience mic
does a lot if I take it out. [music]
So, we're going to want to blend it in a
little bit. So, let's see. Let's see
what sounds what feels natural. [music]
I think that sounds great. Let's do
that. And then I want to add some room
reverb to it.
All right. At this point, we've got the
backbone of the track. But this is where
things start to get much more lively.
But before that, hi, I'm Matt. I'm a
music producer. And if you're an artist
looking for someone to help turn your
demos into fully polished and finished
tracks, go ahead and click the work with
me link below. Send me your music. Tell
me about your music. I would love to
help you finish your songs. Anyway, back
to the video. It's time for step five,
pedal steel and fiddle. I find that
pedal steel and fiddle really create
that sense of like human connection. A,
it feels like there's more people in the
room responding to each other. And B,
the way a bow swells or a note slides
really feels human and almost sad. For
this, I'll be using the fiddle by
Indigenous Sounds. It's a contact
instrument. So, I think the fiddle is
going to come in last course. I want the
last course to be big. Last choruses are
kind of supposed to hit home the
message. So, let's make it big. Let's
make it memorable. Um, let's figure it
out.
That sounds pretty good. All right, on
to the pedal steel. This is the Ink
Audio Ink Steel. It is so so good.
There's a couple of good ones out there.
So, this instrument is really cool
because you can use this little
modulation and pitch wheel right here.
You can't really see it, but just trust
that there's a pitch wheel right here.
Um, to do stuff like this,
like that. However, with the steel, I do
want to add some distortion. Put some
little overdrive on there.
Okay, after that it's time to add one of
the most classic sounds in country, a
banjo. Now, I'll be honest, I don't
really play banjo. Kind of works in my
favor, though, uh, cuz I can add some
like humanness and like authenticity,
even if I don't really play the banjo
too well. Anyway, I kept it pretty
simple. Played what I thought would
interact well with the rest of the
instruments. I actually did two banjo
tracks cuz I just like the way they
sounded. And I used a real banjo, but
you can totally use a VST here. Um, in
fact, if you find a good banjo VST, let
me know what it is because I've been
looking for a good banjo VST. Haven't
found one.
>> Banjo time. Banjo time.
And it's in tune.
Alrighty.
And then we'll just put some reverb on
them. And finally, it's time to bring
the story to life with step seven,
vocals. For this, I wrote and recorded a
little chorus. I actually used two vocal
tracks. I used a main lead vocal and a
little tiny double vocal under it.
[music and singing]
>> September.
>> Um, my vocals are pretty like kind of
lowendy and and boxy in some areas. So,
the first thing I'll do is get rid of
that like weird boxiness. It's around
this area. You'll you'll hear it.
September. I'm also going to put some
autotune on there. If you got a nice
clean vocal, you don't want to do too
much to it. Um, this is a very natural
sounding mix or supposed to be a very
natural sounding mix at least. As for
the sound, it was just some EQ, some
compression, some room reverb to kind of
bake it in and some saturation for some
color. I didn't want to go too overboard
cuz we're not making a dual aa song.
We're making like a nice authentic human
natural sounding song. And once
everything's layered from that single
acoustic guitar all the way to the banjo
and the vocals, this is what we have.
And I [music and singing] could be here
forever. Sit, stare, surrender. Watching
all the planes in [music and singing]
the middle of September under an old
tree. Watching [music] as the clouds go
by [singing]
all night.
And [music] I can play to find you
better. But ignorance is bliss. Sharing
every moment. See the color like
[music and singing] we're kids. thinking
maybe we'll be wrapped up in each
other's eyes.
Thanks for watching. Again, if you want
to work with me, click the link below.
Suggest videos in the comments. And if
you like the content, subscribe. See
him.